and no being bisexual is not a
superpower what's your superpower oh i
can fly
and you what's your superpower i can
like ride dolphins and and i have a
magical trident and you what's yours
i can have sex with different people
so i've been i've been putting this off
for a long time months ago i began
my quest to find a funny feminist
comedian well not even a funny feminist
comedian actually it's because
the bar is lower than that i just they
don't need to be funny all the time
or even most of the time i just need to
find a feminist comedian who can make me
laugh
one time i want just one laugh that's
all i'm asking for i don't even need
them to be funny twice just one time
and so far i've come up empty so i tried
to laugh at samantha b
uh instead i nearly died of boredom i
tried to laugh at hannah gatsby
and said i was depressed for three days
afterwards tried to laugh at chelsea
handler
and instead i left only feeling very
concerned i'm not suicidal you don't
have to worry about it
i did not laugh at any of their jokes or
even come close to laughing so
today i'm getting back on the horse and
we're going to try to ride this thing to
victory
today i will try to laugh at one of the
newest comedy sensations
in the female comedy space her name is
lily singh
she was a popular youtuber who then
became a late night host
i just found out about her existence two
days ago so that's how plugged in i am
to everything
she replaced apparently carson daly
carson daly has had a job on television
for about 73 years
a little mummy reference a little joan
rivers put them together it's funny
it's not easy to fill those shoes is
what i'm saying lily singh is trying
feminist lover she's a big star
apparently maybe she's the one who can
crack the code
let's find out we'll start with uh this
is a bit she did
on international women's day i am pumped
because
this sunday we're celebrating
international women's day y'all
now don't worry you don't have to
remember to go out and get anyone
flowers
you just have to remember to go out and
fight for equal pay for women in the
workplace
i think it's by the checkout at cvs
now i know there are guys out there
thinking international women's day why
don't we have an international men's day
god bless you twitter well you're in
luck because you do
it's actually on november 19th but you
wouldn't know that because you're too
busy celebrating it every other day
of the year
[Applause]
why do i do this to myself why do i
do this i don't i'm i'm just doubting my
own
life choices this is the level of humor
that we're we're starting with
every day is men's day it's so
unoriginal and witless that you may as
well not say anything
there's no point of even making the joke
if that's if it's between making no joke
or pulling a joke from a facebook meme
from five years ago then you may as well
make no joke at all you may as well get
up there for your monologue and just
stare
blankly into the camera that would be
significantly funnier than this so far
by the way you're damn right lady every
day is is men's day every day is my day
as a man
you are damn right every day could be
your day too if you just
went out and asserted yourself instead
of whining about sexism
and being so damn focused on how
everyone else feels about you
you know when you sit around demanding
that other people affirm you and
celebrate you
if that's how you live your life then
yeah you get one day a year that's all
you get
i take every day i go and take it okay
not funny so far but maybe this will get
better let's keep listening also
fun fact november 19th is also
international toilet day now
i'm not i'm not saying men are toilets
but
both holidays are mostly catered towards
a bunch of white john's
oh my god oh my god
lord save me deliver me from this trial
white
john's that joke made the cut consider
this
okay this is a late night show
presumably they have some kind of
writer's room you wouldn't know it from
the material but i assume they do so
there were a bunch of jokes that didn't
make it to air
right they actually threw out jokes
because they were worse
than that maybe there's a brilliant
writer in that room
probably a man let's be honest no
offense it could be the second coming of
richard pryor in that room
writing material and maybe her sense of
humor is so bad
that she throws those out the brilliant
material should i don't like that
white john's though that is killer let's
do that
this is the female equivalent of
basically a dad joke
but dad jokes don't work unless they're
coming from a dad i don't mean to be
sexist but you got to be a man to pull
him off
you can't do a dad joke in a dress is
what i'm trying to say
i feel like not enough people know about
international women's day
i remember i asked one guy if he knew
what iwd
is and he said yeah can you believe
george bush lied about them being in
iraq
what is you talking about according to
wikipedia
international women's day is only an
official holiday
in 26 countries and wait for it the us
is not one of them that's right
essentially it's the difference between
how i'm treated on this show
and how i'm treated when i try to get a
drink at a bar
what lily you don't have to do this
to yourself you really don't you had a
good thing going you had a good life
yeah your youtube channel you're making
money
this is so bad that carson daly
is starting to look charismatic by
comparison people are actually
pining now for the comedic genius of
carson daly
that's how bad this is maybe that was
the the plan all along by nbc maybe they
were
they just brought her in to make people
appreciate carson daly more i don't know
do you know why international women's
day isn't an official holiday
in the u.s because it's stupid why would
we have a holiday to celebrate women
yes celebrate certain women if you want
to be celebrated go out and do something
to be celebrated
for not just because you're a woman
that's not an accomplishment to be one
tell a funny joke lily that'd be an
achievement
you tell a funny joke and uh i will i i
will i will
name a holiday after you i'll build you
a statue i'll name a galaxy after you
just tell one funny joke that's all i
ask we're gonna try one more
and this is one okay i figure you know
this one is it's got a lot of views on
youtube this this particular uh
segment and really popular so
who knows maybe this is the one let's
listen and today
we're gonna talk about lgbtq plus
issues
[Applause]
okay i made a huge mistake this there is
no way
that this woman is gonna take this
anywhere funny
that's right twitter starts your engines
now as some of you may know
about a year ago i came out as bisexual
i tweeted out
female colored bisexual throughout my
life these have proven to be obstacles
from time to time
but now i'm fully embracing them as my
superpowers no matter how many
boxes you check i encourage you to do
the same and i really do
i encourage you okay
they're applauding her tweet that's what
we've been reduced to
and no being bisexual is not a
superpower what's your superpower oh i
can fly
and you what's your superpower i can
like ride dolphins and and i have a
magical trident and you what's yours
i can have sex with different people so
no not a superpower
also not funny so we haven't got to the
funny part yet
and i'm increasingly despairing of the
possibility that we ever will you know
what i i was going to add to here but i
just thought
let's be totally fair okay this is this
is all material from last season of her
show
i think it's from 2020. she has a new
season that just came out this is just
the most recent episode of hers
and let's uh let's see if it got any
better let's talk about bridgeton
so it's been a month since bridgerton
came out and it continues to dominate
the conversation on social media like
straight up my twitter feed looks like a
19th century lookbook and i am not mad
for those of you that don't know because
i don't know you're living under a rock
what are you doing
the netflix show is an adaptation of the
book series by julia quinn and it is set
in london in the 1800s
essentially it's a story of noble
families that attend balls and try to
marry their daughters off
in other words it's a period piece that
skips all the boring stuff about trade
routes and instead focuses on the
dresses and the sex
nope nope not any better um still have
not splurged on that comedy writer yet
so
it's only gotten worse somehow plus they
they seem to have taken her microphone
away too
next step is to turn the camera off turn
the lights off
and just spare me spare the world of
this because i can't take any more of it